so you can perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast we're here to talk
about life
problems accomplishments drugs and
everything in between
today we have a very special guest i'm
very excited
i i'm i'm going to call him activist
cool ass [ __ ] my friend and
rockstar above all else this is shavo
from system of down thank you for
thank you for coming man man it's always
my pleasure to be around thank you for
being here dude
i appreciate you yeah thank you no
problem we're friends and all that i've
been doing my research
i wanted to i want to yeah yeah i wanted
to talk a little bit
not just hey what's up guy no no it's
all good bring it up
even though that's fun i i have a few
key points you have a list
i did my homework all right i got my
little notes right here
it's cool you like this yeah exactly
behind the shoe no i was just talking
i'm gonna hook right here so i can put
my notes like i'm cheating and [ __ ]
oh good then i'll stop smoking no you're
good i'm
yeah so i want to start it off real
quick we met
about a year and a half ago we were just
talking about it yeah
i want to talk about something i don't
think i ever told you
i think i was nine years old all right i
was nine years old
spiders was on the radio my dad is he
loves rock right he's a truck driver
okay we're on the way
to l.a on the grapevine and i just
remember the trail of lights that goes
up
you know as a kid you're just like you
remember those little moments yeah i
remember it
and spiders started playing my dad
turned it up and it turned it off and he
goes these people are gonna be [ __ ]
famous and i go
probably probably and that's the first
time i've ever heard this movie down wow
so i was 98
i was 99 yeah i was nine yeah exactly i
was nine
that's crazy bro that's the first time
you're dead yeah i i remember
my my dad doesn't comment often i
remember when he commented like
yeah he goes oh yeah they're gonna be
[ __ ] big that was it that's the first
time i
ever ever heard oh yeah bro yeah i've
been uh we never got into this i
i have every single album you do that's
so cool
that's great when they came out oh i
remember when still this album
came out and i remember thinking is this
on purpose it's all white with black
marker like are we supposed to steal
this
[ __ ] i was like no that was a sam
goodyear sam goody blast from the past
yeah yeah that was made because you know
we had extra songs
and that was an extra song yeah that was
like off of toxic
those were all made during toxicity and
then they just didn't make toxicity the
record
so we was like a year passed and
i think we were going through something
with sony and
i said we said um i bet you we can drop
something right now
and we don't have to put an album cover
we don't have to make a video
and it'll still go platinum and it was
just like a i think it was like a dare
or a joke or something
it happened that way so i was like okay
let's call it because i had just
read the abby hoffman book uh steal this
book
and so which i just saw that movie the
paris seven movie which is really cool i
will talk about that
but oh it's amazing on netflix it's the
trial of the chicago seven sorry
and uh it's really cool about 68 the the
riots that went down uh
uh during the democratic convention
there it was cool [ __ ]
uh anyways um so we
found like the 10 or 11 i don't know how
many songs are on there that we dug
because there are still songs we never
even dropped that's that was that our
expression from that whole
era yeah um and we put it together we
love to
arrange like sequence albums darren's
really great at that so
he got his hands on it we arranged it a
certain way and uh
i wrote everything it's all my
handwriting on there is it really i just
kind of
wrote everything out and said here guys
i still got it and you know gave it to
sony with no cover
we said don't put a cover we actually
did drop 50 000 each band members
own album cover like
like so if you got a special yeah i drew
my own album cover
darren his john did hysteria did his and
we dropped a limited amount of each
cd so that came first and that went bad
it's like 200 of those 200 000 of those
and then the other 800 like went like
the 800 000 went like that yeah
and i remember remember when you get a
million on there i was like
we didn't have like radio we didn't have
a video that's the power of
of loyal fan it was really yeah that's
when you know you're like a cult thing
it is a call it is it truly which is so
cool it's it's you know
right yeah yeah that like i'd rather be
that than than be that one
giant yeah [ __ ] that yeah i know like i
always say if i don't ever get paid off
this is great people
live and die by some of this [ __ ] they
watch it every [ __ ] day like in
the office that's all i want i'm telling
you it's been 15 years since we dropped
the record today it's still today i
dropped the north kingsley little post
people still wrote behind it where's the
new system right now like dude
well i mean you know yeah i've seen a
numerous amount of your interview
interviews it's
it's not it's nothing bad it's not like
you guys went
[ __ ] you no no yo we are [ __ ] at a
stalemate of each other let's go live
our lives for a minute dude that's the
whole point yeah that was what we did
and we're not going to do it just
because
yeah no no it wouldn't ruin the legacy
or whatever it is
whatever you want to call it we wouldn't
would ruin what we've already done so we
we don't want to release nothing half
fast even the last two songs we did for
the armenia
the uh protect
yeah those two
we made sure it's something that could
have landed on any of those five records
you know oh dude i watched them yeah
i why like you know when you when you
see something when you're younger and it
comes and you're like yeah it comes back
for yourself yeah it's just a nostalgic
yeah yeah yeah yeah just seeing all them
together
all of them all of you guys together
it's different when you talk about it
it absolutely actually feels good it
felt good to be with everybody you know
that's there's like something special
that the four of us have
doesn't matter what's been said what's
been done we're together there's this
cool energy
that doesn't change which is you know
i'm grateful i can't think of what i
don't have i'm thinking what i do have
and i'm going to be very grateful for it
of course man you uh like i always say
i always wonder how does it feel to be a
[ __ ] rock star
and i always imagine you don't really
think about it it's not really something
there you just appreciate the [ __ ]
see it happened to me really early i was
21.
when you guys got signed yeah really so
i was like 21 22.
you guys you you got your your first
record because i know rick rubin helped
you guys with the
was it all of them all of them he's on
all of them oh i thought it was just the
first
except the last two songs oh so okay
gotcha the last ones we just spoke of he
didn't produce those but it's all
through american
columbia sony so yeah that's our yeah so
your first when you guys got signed that
was my next question yeah um you guys
got signed you were 21.
20 97 so we started when i was 21 i
think
we started the group i was like 23 22 20
there's still right it's a pop like
yeah it's like when you guys started
this was 23. yeah see it's a big thing
yeah we started the band i think when i
was 21. so yeah it was didn't take very
long man
two and a half three years until i got
the note you know we got noticed but it
was grind bro we grinded l.a
was before the internet you're out there
yeah [ __ ] shows
phones of course walking in at the front
just yo listen
with before we had music we had a logo
i so the first demo cover is this dude
with his hands
his he's tied he has duct tape he's
wearing glasses
you know really clean cut hair he was a
friend of a friend
and i found out later he he he was
schizophrenic
but but he had this look in his eyes you
know i i guess they had diagnosed them
later of that
i didn't know at the time yeah and uh he
had a look in his eyes he was hanging
out i was like
you look really good tied up what system
of a down written on your chest
i don't know how i made him do it i
didn't make him did i just said that yes
and he got excited he was like i'll do
whatever because we had already you know
talked about what's going to happen we
didn't even have a demo nothing you know
we
were just practicing yeah we were
practicing we had a few songs written
you know
i started doing i started thinking about
marketing like
what are we going to look like what's
going to be the logo how's that you know
what i mean what kind of
images we're going to use what colors
are we going to represent and [ __ ] like
that
and i had no idea that was called
marketing and branding back then i was
just just doing it
yeah i think if i was somebody else how
would i appeal yeah there's companies
right now that do
yeah that's it that's one out there
they make a lot of money doing it oh we
just found out yeah those agencies are
seriously broke deep and we can talk
about that too i've dealt with them too
anyways so um i took the picture and i
went to kinko's i had some friends that
worked at kinko's you made it yourself
you got everything
i took the picture of my dad's house you
know my parents house
i still lived there until our like
second third tour i was still living
like until i was 26 years old i was
living with my folks because i didn't
want to you know leave them there you
know
we're helping each other out you know
and right here you said kingsley right
kingsley was where you grew up la
hollywood that's where i grew up
and then we moved to glendale burbank
after that
and oh no [ __ ] yeah so it was burbank
area so um
we did that and the reason why i'm even
telling the story is we didn't have any
music like to
show to people but i would go to the
shows in la like at the whiskey
at the roxy at the troubadour and i had
i had made flyers with that guy
tied up with this move down written on
his chest with my mom's lipstick
and and uh and and said coming soon and
i didn't let them know what it was i
just kept passing these flyers
so so people look at the image what the
[ __ ] is this right it's enticing yeah
and then what kind of name is that
system of a what you know
and then it says coming soon what's
coming soon i was like it might be
really cool to like not even let them
know what it is
that's that's a marking team you just
pull it as a kid i did that
and then um then i was trying to get
shows
and they wouldn't give us shows because
it was all pay to play but it was you
had to have a demo but we didn't have
any money we were all living in our
parents house
again they're looking at you like hey
kids you have nothing to show me i'm not
doing i don't even know what you're what
you sound like and i'm like how do i
explain our sound right so i'm like well
it sounds like this
and they're like no yeah we need a demo
so i'm like guys we got to put some
money together
get a demo she had no music at all and
you guys are just trying to and we were
no we were rehearsing yeah of course we
just had nothing recorded there's no
computers like you can make
music out of confidence dude yeah you
guys like yo we got it we should you
know get it together now
yeah let's get the show so we put like
six seven hundred bucks together
and um found some guy recording
like a recording engineer um i remember
who it was bro
but it was someone cool and um we went
in
to his back house studio his garage with
pro tools
um this right here is thousand times
better production than where we were at
you know
yeah and it was all like on on a adat i
think realtor real we were still using
them nothing digital at the time it was
really tough and we've still put four
songs together
i made the demo i found a guy that makes
like armenian
mixtapes so he did the art he was right
here
yeah he did all the set art so we made
set tapes of um
and i kind of designed it you know i
made it happen his name was z i remember
his name
and he made the demo and then we made
little posters out of it that kinko's
i'd go to kinko's
i'd like cut like i'd cut them i'd make
xeroxes i'd like you know with the
with the glue stick you know all that
stuff and then like make xeroxes and
then cut them into four and then go
and like have stacks then go make
stickers that peeled off right away but
we would go and
stick our melrose all over the place
we'd do all the you guys are street
marketing
full-on i mean it's pre-internet man
listen wait for you
this is what you had to do what's your
name out there
no one's gonna know the [ __ ] we are yeah
and then you know what else we do we
would um
we couldn't get the shows so we had a uh
a warehouse studio
up on lankershim off of lancashire and
uh
sadako in lancashire where we have sushi
now yeah
i know exactly what the area you're
talking good spot yes um
and we would bring our friends over and
our friends would call friends and we'd
do these little practice shows
at the rehearsal space so people would
like pack up and we'd play like through
our seven songs that we had really yeah
and it was it was a
it was a party band [ __ ] dude yeah yeah
and
everyone watches playing like wow that's
kind of cool what they're doing it's
kind of different you know it was kind
of starting the whole little
it was where we started the spark you
know i'm saying because
an inferno occurred years later but it
all started from a little spark
you know yeah it gave you guys the
motivation of like oh no people feel
this
yeah because it's always cool when you
love it and it's like
you love it no matter what even if
people don't like it but it's always
great to go
it's kind of like the approval of the
masses of like the peers you know like
they were all our peers and family and
friends and cousins and [ __ ] you know
i was still going to glenda college
right here i was studying psychology and
like
art on you know art and psychology i was
like i love art i always love art it's
always going to be
a thing inside can you paint good can
you draw i do but i don't
i did more when you don't do it for a
while you're not as you know
you can draw i used to be able to i was
a a-plusing all my classes
good [ __ ] yeah so i like i have no i i
love it that's how it started you know
withdrawing and painting
um i do abstract stuff that's what i
call my [ __ ] i love this [ __ ] you know
oh
deanna she did this beautiful sick right
yeah
i love it i love it i love all kinds of
expression man so
yeah that's how it all started and then
um once we had the demo
uh i started oh you know what we
actually got the shows without the demo
bro
um at the roxy right first show yeah but
the way it was is i kept calling the
roxy up because i worked at a bank at
the time
down in downtown doing wire
transmissions i was doing wire transfers
i wear a suit and [ __ ]
pre-beard it was like a little like that
maybe or maybe a knot bro
with a fro you know um oh i can't even
imagine oh dude i have pictures
[Laughter]
uh well it's out there you can find them
i have some with like a raccoons
you'll find but yeah it's hilarious my
my graduation picture was the craziest
i actually chase just saw it uh he's
like you got the mullet they go hell
yeah
you're rocking it yeah i was rocking the
mullet okay yeah so
um i would call after every wire
transfer i would
call the roxy and like no one knew i
have the head head piece on
my cubicle i had my i had a cubicle i
worked in the cubicle bro
so i'm doing the wire transfers thank
you for calling so-and-so bank and then
it's like
roxy how may i help you hey this is
shovel from system over down who
yeah man you know um we have this i've
told this story before but
it's always fun to say
frantically the whiskey then the
anti-club then and they would all just
no man you don't have a demo tape
there's millions of bands right now that
want a gig you know
it's the 90s yeah bro it's when it was
popping it had popping
it was like tool just came rage was
coming out of there
corn had started you know and and then
it was just and then we were just like
on on the back end of all that you know
inspired by that but more we were like
mentally in your own shape yeah we were
metal heads
we wouldn't compare to any of them any
other stuff weird right yeah we still
love all of them
i love all of them we were metalheads
that listened to the beatles i think
that's what we were first album yeah
please pleased me with my first album
i mean legendary like songwriting
just exactly it's just poppy without
being poppy yeah
without being cheesy thank you yeah even
though they did get cheesy for a while
in the beginning but then they went into
the whole actually the police please me
album was a little on the
boy bandy yeah [ __ ] but you had to
do that to be noticed
and it was the 50s 60s they had to look
like that bro they had to 10 years later
they're all an asset doing whatever they
want yeah which is fine
which is great because most bands they
start off all hardcore and then become
pop just to sell out
these guys started that way but then you
can't do what they wanted to do because
that's what they
they were given the the key card you
know yeah yeah once you're validated
like that like no no
whatever you do do whatever the [ __ ] you
yeah which is the best yeah
um so i have a question for you oh wait
the shows let me finish oh yes
yes so i made these calls couldn't get
the shows and then some dude one of the
guys at the roxy goes hey call this
number
this guy's a um this guy's a promoter
called this guy up told him the story
he's like all right how many tickets can
you sell i go as many as you give me
i was very confident give me 75 we sold
like over a hundred something
nice we did like friends and everything
everybody we just said like
each friend sold like six seven you know
how hard it is to do that before [ __ ]
texting oh yeah bro there was nothing
like that you had to go to the gym
dude i would sit even later on in my
life like when system is big i'd i'd
like pass out like you know
we get comp tickets a few of them that
when we get like the our price of the
good seats for our families and stuff so
and friends i would like meet up with
people you know personally hence you
know like it's just you have to do that
that's
that's why that's why the following's
like that yeah so we got the show when
we sold tickets and we killed it
and our crowd came blew it up it was may
28 1995.
i don't know i remember the dancing at
the roxy it was like seven bands we were
right in the middles all ska bands and
us
no one knew what we sounded like we have
a demo tape
[Laughter]
we came off blasting opera opera
sounding metal right
crazy and it went nuts our crews like
our our like friends and family came in
pitting and it was like a big armenian
wedding but it was a very rougher
oh so they killed there was like skull
like like striped [ __ ]
pants in the air like polka dots in the
air i had no idea what they had no idea
what that
was about and then we came 20 minutes
they they let us play five songs or
something we played five songs and then
we
we uh you know stopped and it was it was
everybody left yeah i was quiet again
the whole so that's kind of like the
stamp of uh and there was a writer that
day from a
paper called uh rock city news and he
wrote that day something
crazy happened in la tonight and that
really was the first time that you
already knew interested in us after that
like what the [ __ ] happened who was it
what a yeah when's the moment you guys
realized that
this is going to take off like was there
a billboard was there
now that was already when that happened
we were just shocked you know when the
billboard started coming up which was
already like one of those like taking
pictures in front of it
of course you have to yeah [ __ ] you it's
it's not even just like
look at me it's more of like look what
the [ __ ] we did yeah we accomplished
it's a proud thing
it's it's it's yeah because we did it
all on our own man yeah hearing that i
didn't know you're out there going to
kinkos oh dude [ __ ] yeah that's
that's how we started i still have that
old briefcase where
inside i have the cutouts that the ones
the actual
original cut and paste really physically
cutting and pasting with the glue stick
and i still have those like
original um ones that we xerox from like
[ __ ] you have to you have to know what i
mean that's what you use the original
pictures
of the guys tied up and [ __ ] like
they'll have all of them yeah
that's good that's that's his that's
historical man
um so my question i wanted to ask you
you said it's been a minute since you
guys put out music
personally me you know what no
how do you feel about rock music right
now today how do you feel about it in
the terms of
i don't you don't
music in general at the moment i'm kind
of like i don't know what to listen to
i'm kind of like conforming
even the hip-hop you know is like [ __ ]
dude it's like there's some coolness i
hear it oh here are the elements that
are cool about it the internet did it
too
yeah they went like you know this is
popular day yeah but tomorrow he'll be
popular
yeah it's totally bought it's yeah it's
bought followers but likes go well
he has a million followers he also
couldn't sell 15 tickets
dude i've seen p there's people out
there 15 million followers who i don't
know their name
oh yeah you know who the ad agency is
going crazy let's make this guy popular
and then there's all these great bands
and great people that have like
you know but it doesn't it's not about
it's not it sucks that it should be
about
it sucks that people see it that way
it's like being in high school where you
need to it's a popularity content
you know a popular kid has to notice you
for you to pop like what is that about
that's crazy not at all but that's what
i'm saying when
good [ __ ] does come out though it goes
everywhere because people
they think like you and i go who is yeah
what is that yeah
like ears go up yep but uh but the thing
is is like the
attention span of people right now kids
is so little
you'd write a three and a half minute
song and then go it's too long you're
like [ __ ] dude if that's too long
you know yeah yeah like north kingsley
for example we've written
we write songs we don't just write beats
you know we we compose
tracks you know and um if you listen you
hear
that in it but a lot of like people i've
heard
i'm not even like you know calling no
one out but there's people that
you know they can't handle a three and a
half minutes song with
with a lot of vocals like hip-hop heads
you know they don't even know who like
who tang is you know what i mean
they come from that's a different
generation yeah they come from the
three-word phrase
which is it has it it's okay it's yeah
i'm not so [ __ ] dick it but it's
crazy i can just change it every time i
hear it because
exactly but i also would rather hear i
like i like like deltron and [ __ ]
delphi coma sapien that's right i like
deljon 3030 it's an hour and a half long
just
lyric yeah yeah yeah storytelling album
see people don't have the patience for
that i love that too but i do have a
three-hour album
[ __ ] uh tribe called question even
like the whole scenario
the skits the yeah the midnight marauder
[ __ ] that's
so cool like the first time i heard it
was fuji's
yeah my mom was playing fuji's and they
go why are they ordering chicken wings
at this restaurant had the whole story
albums right the de la soul three feet
high rise
me too bro i also grew up on a lot of
like led zeppelin pink floyd with my
mom's
classics yeah i'm used to seven minute
songs
that's funny me too albums that's cool
like i'm releasing songs because i feel
like if i dropped an album it would just
go like
unnoticed so i'm doing songs i'm doing
three songs at a time you know
like i see what you're saying because
it's the way of the world right now
yeah like we said earlier you guys had a
cult following you have a cult following
but it's me i'd be you know hyped i'd be
right now i'm
actually releasing it now i'm like get
the [ __ ] but that system i'm talking
like north korea
that's exactly what i'm talking okay
yeah but i'm saying you have a following
enough to where people go if you're
doing it it's not [ __ ] truth and
they just want to hear
they want to hear something because
which again i'm grateful for
yeah it's going and i like the way it's
going because it's it's not like
peaking you know it's like going like
this it's not going down at all it's
just kind of like steadily moving
which is how i kind of planned it uh you
know i'm
it's it's switching of genres like
people don't you know
i haven't heard um like i told you when
i first heard i haven't heard anybody
try this
mix of rock and rap or rock and hip hop
and so [ __ ] long it was
and just back in the day it was called
rap rock now i and i never want to redo
anything but i do love both genres right
but i don't want to do like
i don't want any bands but like a lot of
bands came out back in the day with like
you know including lincoln park
including like
there's so many great thing people that
have done it and it's a great thing i'm
not knocking nothing but i didn't want
to do what was done that's all
so i took what we i love from today's
hip-hop which are the beats the beats
are some of the beats are really dope
i was like we if we use the hip-hop
element as the foundation and put
guitars and bass on top of it
then it's not rap rock it's just heavy
hip-hop you know what i'm saying
that's why you split that up it's a
little different because rap rock is
when like you're playing rock with a
drummer and a guitar player and a bass
player
and someone's rapping over the whole
thing yeah but if you're taking
the basis of like the foundation to beat
like trap beats with like the heavy 808
instead of
that shit's cool when you're cringing i
love it too bro so when you hear that
and then you add this new element that
you bring because i'm like known for a
certain style of riffing and certain
vibe right so i put that on top of it
and then
that's why i think like our unit works
i mean the other two guys sorrow and ray
we
have our own things we do in the group
and there's never an overlap of like oh
i want to do everything
you know it's just it's more like that's
what i mean yeah and then
we just keep growing every every three
four songs we write
it gets to another level where i'm like
oh i can't wait for people to hear this
now because it's just
that excitement like yeah you might miss
that i love it
15 years we didn't release nothing with
system i missed
new music i missed you you're doing all
that non-stop to
dry spell is must you must be going
crazy i was going crazy i'm better now
those first couple years were rough yeah
bro the first not even touring
no we didn't tour in the beginning we
stopped in o6 didn't tour like
until i think eleven
2011 yeah that's when we came back then
we uh we we did like
a small tour every other year and that's
what we've been doing just kind of like
going out there giving
shows we i mean i live on there but i
love st i love the stage i can't wait to
take north kingsley live which is the
next step we have to like
do these songs live so yeah we wrote
them in the studio we need to now
do them live and perform them your other
band members are they um
pre-existing musicians that they've been
on tours and whatnot no they haven't
they're
wow they're both uh they've seen talent
in this
yeah yeah i mean it started off with
sorrow
he uh i wanted to learn logic and
because i know pro tools but i wanted to
i heard it was easier and stuff so i saw
i met him at a friend's studio
he was so brilliant like i was like okay
this guy can help me so i said
i'll pay you bro come through the studio
to my studio teach me once or twice a
week
he came through the second third time it
was already we had something
made where he was so fast my ideas were
coming out and his ideas
combined were making really cool tracks
i was like okay we can be this whole
producing duo i was like where we can
like make music for others
he had this band for like a few months
called uh
heavy shepherd with rey and ray was a
singer and he was just making beats
and you know it was it was really good
but it wasn't
what we were doing now and i loved rey's
style
he came in he put some vocals down
we chopped it up i did the whole
executive producing thing that i've
watched rick do for so many years like
you know say this twice shorten this
lengthen this put this
yeah this whole process
that grew on me after watching my band
yeah the finals right in your as you're
seeing yeah that's [ __ ] incredible so
i do that to it and all of a sudden we
have a track i'm like so this could be a
band
you know for the [ __ ] six months it was
just a production crew
then ray came in and it was a band so
then we had to start thinking about
naming it so it's been like two and a
half
three years ago yeah because when i
first met you you told me that you were
about to announce something serious yeah
and this is it this is it and this was a
year ago when i realized
oh wow it's been a year and i feel like
this could be a band now because it's
really tough bro i'm
i talk about i'm system i'm i'm
identified as the
band member of system so it's like
feels like you're married and then like
you have this other now i have this
other band that's like i have to call
mine you know it's like
how do you love something and love some
of it two things at the same time yeah
so it took a second you can but it's
just a different thing because it's the
loyalty
yeah it's i'm that guy which i'm very
loyal to whoever
i'm with and um so it took a second
to like take it in and be like oh i can
do this and this
if that wants me i'm there you know if
system's active i'm
always there you know what i mean i'm
never the one to say i don't want to do
something with system i love working
with them i love doing what i got to do
so when everyone's on the same page
let's go well when we're not i can't sit
around and like not
work it's another out it's another
years go by and go i wish i would have i
wish i would have yeah i wish it would
have whether it's good or bad
i need to let it out i've done it for so
long in my life that
for not to do for me not to do it now is
is a shame you know
or would be a shame and there's another
like we said earlier there's another
thing
it's not so much for you it's for the
people and for them to
you know you make people's [ __ ] day
when you announce some new [ __ ]
true you know but i'll be honest it
sometimes has to do for b
for you oh okay yeah i i love the fans i
love giving them stuff and i love making
them happy but
you know with the trolls out today but
i'm just saying
it's some it started off being for me
because even if no one was going to hear
it i was going to make it
exactly and i i totally understand what
you're saying
that's what i'm saying even if no one
when you first started yeah if you love
it
i love it yeah it's okay we didn't start
system to be famous
of course we started because we loved
making music i didn't start north
kingsley for north kingsley to become
famous i just did it because
i needed to make music again and i found
two guys that agreed on the same things
i agreed with and we we met
you know somewhere and it's happening
and it's just the music's flowing faster
than ever right now
where i'm like trying to think of like a
strategy to drop the next five or six
songs you know
no [ __ ] i'm driving six well we have ten
ready to go almost maybe like eight or
nine races almost a [ __ ] album
yeah and we've already dropped six and
we're about to so i was gonna do threes
i i had announced that i'm dropping 12
songs in three years
you totally told me that i've dropped
the first two i'm like i don't know if i
want to drop another three i feel like
doing a bigger thing
and like holding back for a few months
and then and then really
you know yeah i mean that's what my gut
says yeah that's why i halted i halted i
was like
we were gonna drop three more songs in
like a month month and a half and i'm
like you know let's pull back
let me think of what i got to do here
and i'm thinking how to market not
market but how to roll it out you know
where it's it's fun for people too you
know it's fun and it's not just
lost in a post it can't be yeah you
don't hate that it's
it's [ __ ] aggravating yeah i know
exactly what and since i don't have like
i'm the record label it's like oh you
guys doing all this everything on my own
yeah
on by ourselves yeah but that's how it
should be that's how we started
you know yeah exactly i mean the kink
yes you're [ __ ] making sure that
kinkos man if someone told me how to do
things it'd be awkward you know so i
kind of
i'm making my own mistakes and learning
from them you know
still until today i saw the uh one with
rizza the video with rizza do you i saw
that you were directed
or you not that one but the one before
in the burned house
yeah i love that was done right here um
yeah man that was so fun i did it
with um a team i hired because there was
so much happening at that time
that i just kind of didn't want it
because directing a video is not
like oh i have an idea then one day you
film it and then you're done with it
it's like a whole month and a half two
month process you know
like i did the last system video with uh
with adam mason and that was
oh the uh the one where you guys are in
this with the cartoon yeah yeah with the
cartoon oh yeah
the animation thing the white over the
black yes yes
so that was a concept i thought of and
then it became and we were gonna do it
real life but then like the kovitz thing
was where we could
we even found the kid to play that role
and we found a place where
it looked like a war-torn city it was
like a sound stage
really but then because of covet the
scheduling went [ __ ] and then
i had the concept of at the end having
hundreds of people
and i was like you cannot get hundreds
of people together right now so
next step was like why don't we try
animation systems never done an animated
video
and um the rest is history and then the
live part was just like me
oh man that she got me that was so rad
only got me hyped i knew it would get
fans hyped that was morally
that was done for the fans i was like i
can't just make a whole animated video
we got to be here
you know how tough it was convincing the
band members to do a video
really yeah i had to call each person
separately and kind of like let them
know
why and how and like everyone agreed at
some point you know because i mean i'm
like i said i'm cool with everybody in
the band you know every i can call
everyone right now and just be buddies
with them so
i mean yeah that's what everybody wants
everybody wants to hear that man yeah
it's true
it's true there's no like bad nothing
you know anyway so
yeah no the video was great i didn't i
didn't know you were the rest of the
video you were talking about yeah the
the false titles yeah that was a
direction
i've also done like five other system
videos from the past directed them yeah
toxicity and aerials and
really question yeah i remember where i
was at when that [ __ ] was on mtv pretty
much
crazy [ __ ] it was nutty seeing like when
mtv would show the director and it's my
name up there was like it was like one
of those things you know proud moment
yeah bro
that's cool what's up guys i know you're
wondering what the [ __ ] is going on
this is officially our first ad read yes
guys dope as usual we got our first
sponsorship
remember all the if you've been
following we've had years and years and
years of content we've been putting out
for free
yes we come out of pocket for videos
editing time
but guys this is the podcast this is a
whole different this is a whole
different lane
we finally got we're official now we're
just like everybody else guys i know we
went from the weed and getting shadow
band and getting kicked off of
everything we are officially
a real podcast we have sponsorships and
today guys our very first ad read i want
to say shout out to my homie dj
afterthought for hooking this up
um to notorious notorious is an ad
agency we just teamed up with
and this is our first ad rate it's our
first sponsorship marty and i are super
super [ __ ] hyped to do this guys this
is what keeps the podcast going this is
what's going to give us the leverage to
pay ourselves
so we're not just coming out of pocket
you guys got to remember that we do have
to get paid
eventually so this is our way of getting
paid don't [ __ ] hate on me all right
we've been doing this [ __ ]
for free for eight years so [ __ ] off all
right
first address coming from stereo stereo
is an app a
brand new app that just came out you
guys know we're in the chat we're in
youtube chat or any other chat
and it's there's thousands and thousands
of people in the chat
you're trying to talk to me get a
message across maybe a comment stereo
app is
basically our intimate version of live
chat so after the shows maybe
on a monday and you're just hanging out
check out stereo app i'll always
announce when i'm going to get on
it's a live chat it's just us do you see
what i'm saying this is a growing app
it's a platform that just started
so it's not like there's going to be 500
000 people on the page trying to talk to
me at the same time
this is for us this is for the fans this
is for us to
talk intimate bonus q and a's so what i
want you to do right now
right now if you support our app i mean
if you support our platform do me a
favor
go download this app it's a stereo app
in the app store download it make an
account
follow us dope as usual right now we're
working on getting verified
the first platform in the world to ever
[ __ ] verify us guys
they play us so much but stereo shout
out to you thank you so much for
bringing us together
and actually being able to make a
[ __ ] platform so we can talk
do you see what i'm saying it's not just
non-stop [ __ ] messages this is us
this is gonna be just for the fans for
the dope as usual fans and this is it
so do me a favor guys if you support the
podcast you want to see us do more of it
this is going to allow us to pay
ourselves
go to the stereo uh go to the app store
right now and download stereo
check it out follow us dope as usual
after the show before the show we'll be
hopping on live
at least two to three times a week guys
we're gonna be using this platform a lot
so thank you guys so much for sticking
around to this long ass first ad read i
know i'm rambling here
but i'm grateful i'm super super happy
we're like everybody else we're like the
normal kids now we can actually
advertise
and not get [ __ ] on because it's a wii
company this is real
stereo app in the app store now back to
the episode
i've like i said did my homework yeah do
you direct it
is this true am i [ __ ] up on the
internet did you direct something for
mortal kombat
yeah yeah yeah yeah tell me excellent it
was easy
they just wanted to use it so they first
asked to use chop suey okay and then but
i said hey if they're gonna use it and
it's gonna be for the commercial let me
direct the commercial
so i did so they left me so they let me
direct the [ __ ] mortal kombat
commercial oh
yeah that was so dope that is sick as
[ __ ] yeah that was fun to do like
in the studio and watching it like it's
a movie and then
i love matching like visuals with
music with sounds you know so let's say
something say there's a guitar
uh slide i'll do like like in in the
video i think i made like
one of the guys i think it was scorpion
or something like scratching the wall
during that slide so it's like
yeah you see the sound kind of happening
yeah um
i did a bunch of [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah so i did a bunch of [ __ ] like that
it was so fun
that's so badass so i wasn't wrong okay
yeah i looked and i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
mortal kombat it's on youtube i think
there's there's like a making of or
something
really yeah it's oh i didn't find that
there's somewhere out there did you see
the mortar
yes you have to see that oh dude you
should have had to make you a character
oh that would i asked you know we are
characters in a game back
i think it's 07 uh game madden
you can you can play with child like as
java with with the jersey 22 and [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] at you yeah
it's pretty cool oh seven i think it's
the 07 one oh seven
i was i think was playstation 3 at the
time i was doing so many drugs anymore
i just got it but um the new mortal
kombat movie is coming out yeah yeah
what about the trailer man you did it's
on it
is it out oh yeah it is i gotta check it
out it just brought me back oh hell yeah
i'm so excited mortal kombat's one of
those things you know
yeah it's a street fighter it's like
it's a cult class it's a worldwide
classic just
but yeah you directed that how what an
accomplishment that's [ __ ] cool see
when you're a fan of something and you
get to [ __ ] with it it just makes you so
cool yeah more exciting that was one of
those like
bucket list [ __ ] you know where is that
exactly i got to [ __ ] with the video get
excited we used to love video games
growing up bro like i was
nintendo first thing you know mario
brothers when that came out
to your house oh yeah when i started
that [ __ ] spot yeah
i i lived by north kingsley on the
corner with shaky's pizza and so i
i got my video game fixed when did you
come to l.a because you're 79. you were
born in
armenia right but in 79 we moved to l.a
hollywood straight to
like north kingsley drive down what a
smack back in the middle yeah it was
great how was that transition
nutty yeah nutty school no i went to an
army
first i went to like a little public
school called ramona elementary
for like six months and then uh my
parents decided to
put me in an armenian like a private
armenian school which at the time i was
like what the [ __ ] you guys doing i want
to be normal
yeah but now i put my kids in one
because
really you know what it is it's there's
this feeling of like culture where you
remember
where you're from you can totally
understand and you know you you still
speak the language
because at home we talk our armenian you
know what i mean and my parents speak
armenia so it's like it's good for my
kids to
get to know where they're we're where
their everyone's from we're all american
yes we're armenian we're american
armenians however you want to put it
like
they're born here they're you know what
i mean that's their thing but they
should know where
their ancestors are from because it's
like if i don't
who's a teacher yeah they won't know and
then their kids will nothing
my grandkids won't even speak armenian
if i don't teach my kids to
you know remember their culture and hold
on to it yeah that's it
so you how old are you when you when you
moved here five
yeah i had never gone to school in
armenia nothing you were a
culture shock [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
when did you would you just become
americanized right when you got here
i i guess i was like you know to me my
parents gave me a skateboard
oh there you go and then my and then i
didn't have a guitar until i was like 11
or 12
but i skated and i did just i was that
kid in the street my parents worked like
two three jobs each you know
they came here with nothing that's my
question they put in private school that
i mean private school was like
we lived in an apartment that was like
nothing so you did not grow up with
money
none okay even when i even when we got
signed i'm telling you we couldn't
we didn't have enough money for a demo
you know what i mean to go and get
one recorded we had to put it all
together to do it you know so we did not
come from money no
we're like it's kind of like the
american dream if you think about it you
know like someone comes to an
immigrant family moves to america their
kid just to give their kid
a better life because you know two three
four yeah because it was the u.s so
sorry back then
where we lived you know it wasn't
armenia was in a free country it was
or a country it was more of a it was a
republic of the soviet union at the time
wow so that's rough dude communist
nation you know damn yeah and then you
know
so they brought us yeah brought me to
l.a and uh the rest is
i saw a mural on sunset of kiss and i
was like oh [ __ ] what is that like i
was my thing and then oh when you were a
kid uh-huh and then that year i saw
i was five years old i remember i
watched them on solid gold
kiss was on a show called solid gold and
solid gold was this like weekly thing
that was like disco and music it was
like a performance show on channel 13 or
something
and uh i don't remember how exactly it
went it was like more it might have been
a countdown show also i don't know
it just was solid gold yeah and kiss was
on there i was like [ __ ] those guys on
that [ __ ] mural that wall that i
drive by all the time
and they're singing music they're
playing music i didn't even know that
was a band i just thought it was cool
with the makeup you know
yeah they looked like they just look
like you know what their music was you
know what i mean and
i'm telling you i didn't care about what
the music was it was the whole presence
was so badass
i was like oh [ __ ] i want to do that so
that's that's where
that's where i can yes yeah because if
you remember that then i remember
that's the [ __ ] right boom i'll never
forget seeing it you know what's funny
uh years later i meet darren and stuff
and he's like yeah he's like when i was
four he's a year younger than me goes i
saw kiss on solid gold i was like what
he swear to god he saw the same
performance he was
one year younger than me and it affected
him what are the odds
should it be crazy right that we tell
each other the same story i was like wow
yeah yeah where did you meet him at
he actually his parents sent him to that
same elementary school for
like maybe a few years he was a year
younger than me so i remember him there
but we never like
traveled it was like each grade had its
own clicks and [ __ ] of course
so um but later i saw him at i was
rehearsing in burbank at some studio
right now it's a piano place but on off
off of verdugo and burbank
there's a studio and i was rehearsing
there with some band and my friends were
rehearsing in another room and darren
came to try out and uh i was in the room
he was going to try out as a singer but
he played awesome guitar also
they played like a bunch of covers and i
told my friend who was the main guy in
the band i was like
yeah i go make him your singer and your
guitar player
oh [ __ ] there's a guitar player that was
with them i was like he doesn't fit the
mold
how old are you how old was i at the
time yeah when you met him 20
21. oh so this is you guys saw something
and just said
i was like no i was like no no i was
just i was in a band
and i was in a room oh [ __ ] he came to
try something
that was there and i just came in to
like he wanted my opinion he was like
i want i want you to tell me what you
think of this new guy coming in
and it was there and i was like and
there was no hope of like
talking about being a band with him it
was just trying out for my friend's band
so i was in there
and i told my friend later this is the
guy bro he's [ __ ] rat he sings great
and he plays great
like he he fits the mold you know so he
ended up joining the band
and who would have thought that would
that guy was going to be my law
lifelong guitar player partner you know
like a year later [ __ ] like that band
broke up
they did another band and i managed that
band and that's when soil the old
it's all this [ __ ] like it's like a
puzzle like a web
you know that's the [ __ ] man that's
that's the history
that's [ __ ] awesome cool right yeah
damn that's how it was
out of fate literally just said no he's
[ __ ] awesome he's badass i thought
you know when someone's when when
something's good you say it's good it's
called the speed of spade it's not about
pride or like oh ego it's just
it is what it is bro yeah you know so i
called it out and
you're right that led to [ __ ] like you
know years later
where i didn't expect any of that to
happen you know wow so you
you show up here you go to school with
the kid you remember him go hey didn't
you go to my elementary i said that yeah
wow yeah i did say that at the time i
was like i think i remember you bro
he was quiet kid he was really quiet
just all about his guitar
that's a great story man yeah i don't
think i've ever told that story let's
see yeah i think you just got something
brand new yeah like i don't think the
[ __ ]
people are here there's gonna be
magazines taking that right now and like
posting it
having their own art because that's what
happens when i do an interview and i
talk about system
and they'll pick something out of there
like that's new and make that their
headline
[ __ ] you let him have it watch because i
never
because i never said that darren's gonna
hear him be like i don't remember that
he'll remember that too but he didn't
know that i was there and i told dave
that he was back
i don't think i ever told him so he got
obviously they picked him for that yeah
yeah that's how he
joined the bunch that's how he entered
the that circle
you know yeah yeah so that's how it all
happened and then after that band broke
up they started
he actually played with that band at my
18th
wait was i was it even like
one of my birthday parties he played
with that band
you had a live man on your birthday yeah
and i even did it at my uncle's house it
was in the backyard
and they i you know i could have been 18
not 21 bro i think i was 18
really when that happened because i
remember my 18th birthday party
and they played it and they played hotel
california i remember and i had all my
high school friends there so yeah bro
was 18.
oh no that's trippy so you played two
years first so darren played my 18th
birthday party
that's interesting that's [ __ ]
awesome my 18th birthday i saw stevie b
remember
yeah of course i did yeah
yeah i went to a house music festival my
sister got me tickets
that's great it was [ __ ] awesome
wearing white pants
he was wearing white he was wearing it
you always do because i remember
thinking [ __ ] you got me stevie b
tickets we're going to we're going to
san jose for what
happy birthday and come back to me in
heights man the diamond girl was there
or was that somebody else that's
somebody else say america
samuel yeah there was like you know 50
different people there it was one of the
festivals
real quick i saw something and i want to
know
i saw you're chilling with trippy red
yeah dude is there is there any talks of
music there is there's a lot of talks of
it i want to hear what that's going to
be like
i can't say nothing i know that
we listen to music together i jammed to
some of his
producers beats i do what i do i do this
featuring thing i do that with
north kingsley too it's like all i'll
take i'll have him play me i did this
with wu tang back in the day i'm i'm on
the
uh only built for cuban links part two
record i'm like really yeah two three of
those songs are like my bass playing
live you know uh yeah yeah we just never
made a thing out of it
um it's [ __ ] awesome though thank you
yeah yeah man that's cool [ __ ]
uh but um so i just did that
and then we just got to know each other
in the studio listen to music and then i
played him from north kingsley and he
like really
vibed that yeah and uh so i might get
him on a feature maybe maybe not on
north kingsley and then
probably yeah do something with him on
his next record because
you know i think i got something up my
sleeve for him his producer asked me for
something i think i'm gonna grab it so
i'll see what happens
i'm not sure i don't want to say
anything do not do it i hate it don't
don't i'd rather have it i saw it
and at least it's like oh i really hope
that's something against
it's crazy right it's just it's like our
genres are so different but it's
very good he's a rapper but there's a
couple times where he's yelling it's
like yo you sound like you're [ __ ]
you're seeing rock singing right now
well he just released the record
with travis barker it's like a oh really
it's like he's singing
he's singing on a rock record it's not
like beats like hip hop yeah
but he's doing like a singing thing like
he's he's a singer
he's the same artist yeah which i really
find um but
admirable like you know the fact that he
he's big at this yeah he's big in this
genre
but he's like [ __ ] it i do that you know
and i just all of a sudden i like this
genre too
why can't i do that because this is
because society
doesn't know me that way yeah like
nobody gives a [ __ ] don't judge me bro
like i hate people that are like oh no
shavo you did hip-hop like oh no now
you're like
there's a lot of comments like that you
know by like close-minded fans you know
that are just like oh he's not gonna do
metal then [ __ ] him
it's crazy that that where we we live in
a
uh time where that's normal relevant
yeah that happens to everyone thing
to the real fans they're going to
support no matter what even if they're
like you know what i'm not really
feeling it
but it's him doing it yeah yeah yeah
that's fine
it's just let me know like it's not just
oh i don't [ __ ] with it because it's hip
hop yeah
that's different that's like so
close-minded though yeah it truly is
even if you don't like it
you know at least give it a chance and
listen once of course and it's not i'm
not talking about us i'm talking about
any music like i think open-mindedness
in art and envision is
is a key to life you know what i mean
it's like it opens you up to so many
different things bro you have to be
you know uh you have to be willing yeah
bro that's really all it is like and
it's like if you want to be a good
artist if you want to create if you want
to write [ __ ]
you got to listen and watch and like you
know what tarantino does this famous boy
he watches
i know tarantino like we've hung out
many times with rizza and stuff
and i'm intrigued by the fact that he
would watch
three to four movies a day every day
seven [ __ ] days a week
inspiration how do you think we'd do it
if we didn't darren list the music
yeah because you had no direction where
are we gonna write crazier music yeah
you know you need to have something to
like
it's inspiration bro that's in you need
inspiration it's not all about
technique it's about inspiration and
having it in your head
so when it comes out of your self it's
original it has
twists and turns you know what i mean
you're more and if you listen to one
genre everything you write is going to
be that genre
of course yeah there's no there's no
expansion there no
i totally understand so that's the part
of it that you know intrigues me is
music and art all is one genres just
exist for categorizing yeah just so you
can find it easier yeah
yeah so if you're into directing and
that's something you do have you ever
thought of directing something
not a filmmaker yeah of course i i just
haven't
gone around to it i guess maybe one day
i just have something i've had
i've had people ask me to do certain
things but i feel like
because i'm already i have a lot on my
plate bro so you know because i have so
much on my plate i just don't want to
put too much more and then
half-ass anything you know of course i
believe in like
knowing your limits and then like
completing what you started
you know it's very important to me too i
feel like i'm preaching but i'm a father
so
no no i tell my kids all this [ __ ] i'm
like you need to be consistent you know
what i mean like don't ever take too
much on because then you'll
i've learned that this past year you'll
deal half-ass [ __ ] bro you need to you
need to
do things the best like 100 percent not
super stoked it could be better
no i never wanted to be like just here
here it is
exactly yeah that's it look at me you
know you're good at this do this you
know
make this blow up first before you like
like 22 red yeah
there's a little good segue yeah exactly
where we go that's what i'm saying
for everyone that doesn't know you
literally curated this [ __ ]
right when i first met you you were
telling me i'm having this strain coming
out i think i'm going to pop this out of
mr jack and i want to get the [ __ ] out
it's so fun to do it's so it's and it's
something that you love and you couldn't
do this five years because
you you weren't all in i wasn't there's
no possible way everything happens for a
reason at the
time it happens and if it doesn't work
out there's you got to think of
something
there was a reason for that not to
happen but 22 yeah man look
um oh yeah this right here like 22
strains later
that's a red wedding yeah it's it's a
it's a pheno of a wedding cake
it's one of the pinots we popped and
you're you're
a real you actually smoke weed because
you like that
constantly yeah i mean i feel like i
said when i first met you i was very
very surprised you know
that never happens like you never think
that because of a celebrity
yeah [ __ ] that no that's why you had
more weird than i did that day
remember you had times five years i was
like try this try that try this i
remember that was the beginning
like none of it's trash what the [ __ ] is
going on i'm sorry i only have one with
me
oh you're serious oh yeah i'm into this
and you were just testing popping [ __ ]
i appreciate that it's not just what is
this called oh is it a hybrid
call it this how much is it does it
leave my budget to buy and sell like
[ __ ] that
white label the [ __ ] out of all of your
stuff i hate it
i [ __ ] and that's why they fail i've had
to at times where we don't have [ __ ]
like or it's not popping it's different
i've had to try to and it's really tough
doing that i can't believe brands do
that like that's how they function
yeah that's insane because they're
functioning bro it's stressful when
you know we have this order this look at
this stuff i'm like
but it's not a you know it's not our
stuff it's like
you can't really be proud of it and if
somebody goes hey look there's mold
but i didn't we just bought it from
somebody you can't say that [ __ ] and i
don't want to be known for that
ever you know so um yeah it's
it's it's pride it's you know we have
certain growers growing our
specific strains that we always have and
we're looking at some new ones right now
i'm looking so forward to that
um yeah man i'm caught in mouth
you're good since i always started
talking about 22 i got caught up since i
last saw you
you know how long it's [ __ ] been it's
been over a year i know because there
was no pandemic we were kicking it at a
at a weed cafe bro that was the last
time i think i saw it right we've been
on lives and facebook we've talked to
each other many times
it's been a minute and since then i've
seen your brand and almost every [ __ ]
store i've been in oh man thank you yeah
well very cool hell yeah man [ __ ] that i
remember you're just starting i remember
you was like yeah we're gonna see how it
goes we're in three states now really
yeah what are the stages we're in
arizona
nevada and not in cali and we're making
some other moves very soon
yeah you have pre-rolls out now i
remember the pre-rolls you gave me i was
very surprised oh yeah we don't use
shaking yeah
everything is nubs yeah it's always it's
it's just to make it more convenient for
the smoker
it's it's not to get rid of our smalls
or our not our smalls but our
shake that everybody always is known for
yeah terrible um what else do you have
coming up we have
i know you have vape and cbd for sure we
have the hemp side and then we have the
thc side which is in all the shops
the hemp side we have the new tinctures
that just came out you could get them at
22rdhemp.com
um we actually every state every state i
put three thousand
milligrams in every bottle which is
usually a thousand five hundred i'm
selling at the same price as the
1000 and it's all cbd no notice all hemp
cbd
um the the terps are all steam driven
steam derived and steam derived our guy
marcus from um nature's lab oh no he
literally steams let's say grapes and
puts it into our
pens the [ __ ] swear like the
watermelon is literal watermelon steam
derived terpene
badass it's he's i don't know who's the
doctor yeah dude he's a genius he is
crazy that's why when i met him i was
like dude this
i see i met him a while ago and i didn't
it was it wasn't about what he did it
was like yeah
he just met somewhere and i wasn't in
the weed game this was like 10 years ago
and uh but you know once we hung out i
found out what he did when
when now i'm in the you know worlds you
don't mean
to stay on the connections like what can
you do no no we were friends yeah and
then when we
when i did start the brand and i kept
telling them i'm gonna start something
soon and if i do you're the guy i'm
gonna do only you i'm not going anywhere
else
and it's three years later we're in
three states he's done every state
steaming watermelons
steaming cinnamon toast crunch well i
should just say cereal
are you serious yeah dude
stop i should have brought something you
know there might be some in your box
that it
rips down into i haven't seen it being
done literally i haven't but
that's what housing does it yeah yeah my
grandpa explained to me how they dried
tobacco with fruit and they'll take on
the flavor that's what it does yeah
yeah yeah so you have an open distillate
i guess wow
yeah yeah how [ __ ] cool that's
amazing right so i've never heard and
it's so natural
and it's nothing like it's not anything
strawberry banana flavor number six
no it's not no it's not it's actual
strawberry banana banana it's
very cool yeah dude so it's exciting so
we have that we have tinctures we just
dropped recently like i said i was just
talking about it we have the pens
um the vape pens which we have six
flavors uh what else what else uh
thc wise we have new flavors coming uh
like i said we're in arizona all
dispensaries nice uh we're in nevada
you just don't do concentrates right we
don't have them yet but we're working on
them as we speak marcus's
so i mean i love his [ __ ] his diamonds
are yeah the first time i saw diamonds
was
on his page dude they're ridiculous and
he does it like in his sleep so
we're working on it at the moment um
what we're doing as a brand though 22
right look we've always
been a brand that always spoke about
artists like and i always do that
because it's kind of my thing you know
yes
and it's something i uh appreciate so we
want to honor
creatives we've always said that's part
of our brand motto so we
we're starting something next week where
weekly art
uh gonna um honor artists like we're
gonna do features on artists that we
like that i like that someone
correct current artists artists past
artists i'm gonna show people i'm gonna
show their i'm just gonna promote people
without having without getting paid
like just like do it for them because i
appreciate who they are from
glassblowers to shoe customizers
to brand artists how are you going to do
that artist i'm just going to find
all their like word i'm actually calling
some of them and reaching out and
they're tripping out like
you're gonna put it in they're like
what's in it for you i'm like no i see
which i'm like what's in it for me
is that i'm i i'm just appreciating you
i'm not
trying to say i'll do something for you
now you do something for me that's not
where i'm at right now i want to just
you know we're a brand we're not just a
weed brand we don't just sell weed
we uh we like to like inform people
about things and like
be creative all our shirts are like done
on
really nice i remember sure it's like
the first photo shoot i ever did with
marty
yeah it was with your stuff hell yeah
and the pens was all your pins yeah yeah
with the comfy you know
like all the artists oh gray yeah bro i
have we have black and something else i
don't know if i brought you any but you
give me a box
let me know yeah it's all good i don't
even know what's in there i just said
pack it
so let me know if there's i want to
bring you some north kingsley gear too
yes ma'am all right before you leave i
mean
as you can see you just came here first
time but we got you oh i finally have
enough room yeah
no i love this i'm very proud of you
once again bro i appreciate it i love
seeing you grow
thank you even when you lost your
youtube page you started you're like
[ __ ] everybody i'm gonna start my own
[ __ ] website
and then you got it back and she's like
marty did that yeah
i already got that back man yeah he got
it back for you yeah yeah yeah
i watch you right follow me and i do
respect it yeah i appreciate you man and
like i said um
i just it's it's so awesome meeting and
like i said getting to know somebody
that you watched your whole life oh yeah
it's very different
it's different like you like you said
where were you in the what was it the ac
dc video
right yeah i was in high school or
college or something at that time
and i just you know we got somehow i got
myself into the crowd and
right next to arnold right he they
brought him right next to me man
i stood in once ac dc video he said it
as a kid
and i'm rocking out yeah and then arnold
schwarzenegger
you think he like throws dynamite or a
bomb dynamite yeah he throws something
they use they use the scene from the
movie there it is
they use the scene yes there i am look
how the lights on me
over over our over someone's hands in
his [ __ ] yeah
and like me i'm like right there it's uh
he's in my shot you know
when this came out it was such a [ __ ]
weird thing because everyone noticed it
was me they're like
why are you more featured more than
arnold schwarzenegger i'm like
at the same year he's doing kindergarten
cop and [ __ ] that's it
that's that last action hero last action
hero
yeah that was the soundtrack for that
for that movie oh you talked about last
night we jumped to the tarp it's one of
my favorite movies that's
from the movie and not in the movie
that's the video for the soundtrack the
big gun
it's so hilarious that like look that
they even have a thing up there with
like
the like me on stage with sister yo see
that's the kind of [ __ ] that's the
that's [ __ ] awesome i'm also
in zoolander like a little background
really i can't believe i'm staying yeah
there's a scene of me in zoolander bro
like you can see my beard i'm behind i
want to know
i'm behind gavin
one of my friends i guess again it's one
of those things like he's like yo uh
i'm an extra in movies and [ __ ] i got an
extra
thing let's go it's this movie it's a
ben's delivery i'm like all right dude
let's go so we
hung out smoking we got really high
this is the story so we had we were just
like sitting with the extras a lot of
a lot of extras because we were doing
this vma [ __ ] like they're making up the
crowd to vmas right yeah
or the model awards and um
i was like dude we're waiting so long we
were like two three hours i'm like let's
go to my car get high
this guy elliott my friend
we went we're getting high we forget
we're like
wanted because we're extras but because
we we knew someone on
the set yeah we were like the major uh
like the ones that are
on camera you know because it's a lot
not just fillers no not
so they're gonna wait for us so now we
we started
now we're stoned we're walking back
really lit like when you're lit you
don't know what's going on and we're
like like some like movies like in um
studios you know big lot you know like
he was like paramount or something i
don't know where it was
and now we're walking back trying to
find where we are and the crowd's gone
i'm like oh [ __ ] where are the extras
there's someone with like
with headphones and papers like the like
the dp or not to dp the
80 like looking for us like there you
are
so so he grabs us and we go inside
and they're filming his ben's still
they're like waiting on you [ __ ]
on me and my friend elliot who are
getting high
in a car
and then we came back and now there's
gwen stefani [ __ ] gavin
that they're the main scene we're like
in their posse you know so we're in the
back
oh i know exactly what [ __ ] scene
you're talking about
so on the wide screen you could see my
you can't see my beard i think
you can't see me you just see my beard
and on one of them you can see me all
the way
like the wide screen and regular tv one
you know hilarious right so
so there's like these two empty seats
and there's a crowd of people so they
walk us up i'm excuse me and everyone's
like [ __ ] like
you're sitting there yeah and they're
with the whole like maybe a hundred
people
you know yeah why are you yeah no one
knew system at the time there was
nothing like that
so i think we were playing but i wasn't
you know we weren't like oh now i'm
gonna have to watch it tonight it's the
scene
that we're watching the awards and we're
in like
oh we're in hansel's crab posse you know
that's such a good [ __ ] movie man
you can't find it look we're all looking
look at the last quick story
everyone's just waiting on your ass
and it was nutty that they waited you
know they but that's the story man one
of those stories that
you know yo i haven't said that story
either that's too many stories i've told
you that no one said
all right man it's all right oh man i
want to ask you something because i saw
it on youtube and i have to know the
[ __ ] explanation oh no
i can't stand being in open water at all
because it scares the [ __ ] out of me oh
you saw me jumping i saw a video of you
jumping into
water and someone says there's sharks in
there it was nice
okay that's my next thing i'm just
watching it right
and i hear you go i'm going to get one
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you there it
is i was i was
um okay so we were on like a three-day
fishing trip with
uh tito ortiz on his boat his brother um
my boy logan made her from uh from
machine head
and um we're gonna do a fishing show
like rock and roll
wrestling fishing and that was the
teaser bro
so we uh and i was i happened you jumped
in
it was my stupid idea i got we drank i
drank
i'm just gonna blame myself so i drank
like i have a couple
like this tequila in my hand oh no
everyone's like don't do it bro i'm like
it'll be good for the camera they
literally said
and i'm faded they're like dude we're in
the middle of the [ __ ] ocean you know
the swells and [ __ ] like i'm thinking
it's like a pool right but
as long as i stay within and i'm like
okay and i'm drinking
i'm stupid right now like it's not a
good time for me to make a decision
about jumping in the ocean so i was like
this will be cool
i took a shot and then they're like he
won't go dude he won't go in and then
they're filming though
and i just go and i just realized how
far it is
i went like this and i just went in and
then you know what happened bro they put
that
the safety line they threw that and bro
at some point
i got soaked because the it took me
under i was like
it's really the waves were crazy right
so i'm hanging out for dear life but i'm
acting cool
uh cause that's scary as [ __ ] no it was
scary as [ __ ] look at me
you know i want you guys to look at him
jump face
you didn't put your slides down [ __ ]
up bro
it was about well dude i watched this
whole video and i could have died bro
yeah i could have died i don't know why
you couldn't like now thinking back
thank that so look he comes to get me
why the [ __ ] is tito ortiz right here
that's what i see is his bow
why is he doing look so it's i keep
going further and further
yeah yeah i'm like i'm cool though but
then i realized it's taken me bro
so i was like okay dude uh let me come
back back in so what happened is um
i walked up i think it's in the video i
walk
up and tito was like all right cool he
saw that i was safe because he was
really worried
so he saw that i was safe and he goes
all right boom and he tried to push me
back in
and i was holding oh i saw it right here
watch my choice and now you can always
say yeah
i can't get up look it's pulling me it's
pulling me in the water's pulling me in
i finally get up i'm like yeah is
everybody done i'm still fading
yesterday dickie's on trying to swim
that's the hardest thing in the world it
is it's like it's like
heaviest look it's like
look look like he's he's going to try to
push me and watch i saw oh watch so i
i'm hanging up for dear life
oh [ __ ] i didn't see that part i didn't
see that i thought you got back up he
could i did i did
no i thought he you fell and you oh no
no no i was just laughing they're all
laughing because like he
that was a look i'm like well i see
you're teasing his prime bro i'm so
stupid
he's a scary [ __ ] he's awesome
he's a good guy man he's a cool dude
yeah yeah i had to bring it up and i had
to ask
he had something embarrassing me i know
you have a studio
yeah studio i'm gonna uh get you out of
here
it's good to see you man thanks for
having me thank you so much i have this
for you
yay all right i love gifts oh thank you
remember i i made a comment about this i
said i want to i know i know that's why
heavy heavy duty
it's it is look at that it is nine
millimeter dude i love it it's [ __ ]
nice
yeah it's the double dude only quality
we're trying to do i'm with you bro got
you that i got you
the only way to be yeah thank you thank
you so much for coming dude it's good to
see you man
it's been a long time now that world's
getting open a little more we'll be
chilling
real quick um i did see something online
corn just moved down yeah yeah that was
booked for last year right before the
quarantine
october october that's that's what
they're saying so i hope it happens
this is the third [ __ ] time they're
pushing it so let's see what happens i
just yeah yeah for everyone for all
these
costumes i'm looking forward it's my la
in the hometown yes i told you i love to
play so
bring it on well thank you so much oh
yeah um i got you you're just coming
i'm [ __ ] there descriptions uh all
the links
your instagram your brand 22 red
everything will be in the description
cool for everyone listening in the car
thank you for hanging out with us
chavo appreciate you so much thank you
thank you for hanging out
this has been another episode of the
dope as usual podcast guys thank you so
much for hanging out
have a dope ass day yeah oh yeah brother
that was fun
nice man i said so many stories
see the thing is you just start talking
yeah and it just gets
it happens to me every day man the last
one i did by myself i hope it's not
stupid i hope i didn't say no it's
[ __ ] great because i was cracking up
no you're fine you're fine dude the last
one we did was three almost three hours
it was supposed to be an hour and i just
kept [ __ ] ranting
and look it was three hours so fast
[Music]
this is officially our first post show
ad read
like i said earlier shout out to stereo
for allowing us to be normal kids
you know i mean we're normal we're not
just trying to advertise random weed
companies which is fun i love doing that
but this is an
actual you know widely masked
accepted app do you see what i'm saying
it's not just hey check out this
crystallized thc which is the [ __ ]
but we can't do that on youtube so for
our um podcast channel
this is our first sponsor stereo do me a
favor go right now into the app store
download stereo it's free it takes you
five [ __ ] seconds download it right
now while you're listening to it i don't
care
go download and follow us dope as usual
it's dope as usual on stereo app
it is a live chat this is a live
streaming app i'm gonna be able to
stream
more intimately with you guys not just
because our pages are big
it's rare that i can catch somebody and
put their comment and talk to them
do you see what i'm saying this is more
of do you want to talk to us directly
this is it this is the live chat like a
fun
20-person room i don't know how many
people are in there do you see what i'm
saying it's an up-and-coming app so it's
not like
there's thousands and thousands of
people on our page trying to get a hold
of us
this is more if you have a question you
wanted to ask on the podcast this is the
time
do me a favor go download stereo app on
the app store or whatever
[ __ ] app store you got follow us dope
as usual thank you guys so much like i
said
it's free and it really really [ __ ]
helps us out so thank you so much for
watching
have a dope ass day
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
bye